جددت فرنسا تمسكها برفض قرار قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر طرد سفيرها في نيامي
واكدت ان قراراتها تجاه النيجر ستكون
مبنيه على المباحثات مع الرئيس محمد بازوم
من جهاتهم واصل قاده الانقلاب تحركاتهم ضد
وجود السفير الفرنسي وكان اخرها تصديق
المحكمه العليا على قرار طرده والغاء
حصانته بالتزامن مع مطالبتهم الجيش
بالاستعداد لما سموه اي غزو محتمل
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي خيارات باريس
للتعامل مع تفاعلات ازمه سفيرها في نيامي
وما مغزى حديثها عن ربط قراراتها بخصوص
النيجر بالتفاوض مع
بازوم ما هي الرسائل التي يبعثها اع ل
قاده الانقلاب الاستعداد لمواجهه ما
يسمونه بالغزو وما مدى دقه اتهامها فرنسا
باستغلال اكواس لشن حرب على النيجير ما هي
المسارات المحتمله للازمه النيجيريه على
ضوء هذه التعقيدات وتزامنها مع تطورات
الجابون وفي ظل غياب دعم واضح من حلفاء
فرنسا لفكره التدخل في
النيجر
[موسيقى]
من المحكمه العليا جاءت اخر خطوات تصعيد
قاده الانقلاب في النيجر ضد باريس عبر
تصديقها قرار طرد السفير الفرنسي في نيامي
فورا والغاء حصنته الدبلوماسيه بعد تلقي
رئيسها طلبا رسميا من سلطات الانقلاب بهذا
الشان تحت سطار من مظاهرات شعبيه للتنديد
بمواقف باريس والزامها بسح سفيرها وقواتها
من البلاد تواصل ازمه السفير تفاعلها
منذره بنهايات مفتوحه على مختلف
الاحتمالات ففي فرنسا التي ترى في هذه
المظاهرات حشودا مدفوعه باراده قاده
الانقلاب جددت تمسكها بالابقاء على سفيرها
في نيامي وتاكيد ان كل قراراتها تجاه
النيجر ستكون حصرا عبر مباحثات مع الرئيس
المنقلب عليه محمد
بزومه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس ومن ابوجا
ديفيد اوتو انديلي مدير مركز جنف للامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا ومن
لوس انجلس الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث في المركز العربي في واشنطن ونبدا
مع الدكتور زياد ماجد اذا دكتور زياد بعد
وزاره الخارجيه لدى
السلطات في النيجر تاتي وزاره الداخليه
وبعد وزاره الداخليه قرار من المحكمه
العليا بطرد السفير والغاء
حصانته داخل النيجر كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى
باريس مع هذا المعطى الجديد وكيف يغير في
حساباتها من الواضح ان الاتج التجاه
السياسي لدى القوى الحاكمه الان في النيجر
هو التصعيد تجاه الفرنسيين وطبعا باريس لا
تستطيع الرد بالمثل الا اذا تعرضت قواتها
في النيجر وقوامها 1500 جندي وضابط او
سفارتها وسفيرها تحديدا لاي تهديد جسدي او
امني مباشر ععد عن ذلك سيبقى التصعيد
الفرنسي دبلوماسيا لان باريس لا تجد دعما
اوروبيا كبيرا ولانها تلاحظ ان واشنطن
تبقي مسافه عن ما يجري في النيجير لم تسمي
ما حدث بانقلاب عسكري لان لذلك تداعيات
مباشره وربما تراهن على مفاوضات او تراهن
على ان يكون ما سربته بعض الدول الافريقيه
من البحث مع الانقلابيين بمرحله انتقاليه
ربما بدعوه لانتخابات لاحقا او الاستفتاء
ربما تجد في ذلك مخرجا يوف فر عليها حرج
الاعتراف بالقاده العسكريين الذين استلموا
السلطه وفي نفس الوقت يوفر عليها احتمال
تصعيد لا تريده لكن طبعا تبقى وهذا اعتقد
ستشير اليه تبقى ورقه او يبقى احتمال تدخل
افريقي داخلي ولو اني اعتقد انه يعني
مستبعد سنعود الى هذه النقطه ولكن لا يبدو
بان التصريحات التي تاتينا من فرنسا تصب
في اطار بانها لا تملك خيارات فهي تقول
بان كل ما ستقدم عليه سيكون بالتنسيق مع
الرئيس المنقلب عليه محمد بازوم ما جدول
الاشاره الى بازوم في ظل هذه
التطورات او ما الهدف
منها نعم الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون
ملزم باظهار حزم تجاه الدوله الاخيره في
منطقه الساحل حيث للفرنسيين وجود امني و
اقتصادي مهم ولا يستطيع التراجع عن دعم
الرئيس المنقلب عليه لذلك حين ذكر انه
يتحدث معه يوميا من ناحيه يظهر رفضا لاي
اعتراف بالانقلابيين وبالتالي يدعو من
يمكن ان يتوسط ربما للبحث بمرحله انتقاليه
ومن ناحيه ثانيه يترك احتمالا وهو ان
يدعوه مثلا الرئيس المنقلب عليه الى
القبول بتسويه ما او حين يربط الموقف
الفرنسي بمواقف هذا الرئيس يبقي بابا
مفتوحا لاحتمالات التنازل عن رفض اي شرعيه
للانقلابيين لكن فقط من من باب ايضا
التاكيد بعد بوركينا فاسو
ومالي الموقف الفرنسي في النيجر اذا بدا
ضعيفا او اذا تراجعت فرنسا عن مواقفها
الحاليه تخسر الكثير من هيبتها فيما تبقى
لها من حضور افريقي لذلك لا اعتقد ان هناك
اعتراف دبلوماسي سيحصل في باريس بالسلطات
الجديده لكن ربما يكون هناك قبول بمرحله
انتقاليه تؤدي الى تسويه ما او الى حل ما
لا يتطلب تدخلا عسكريا حقيقيا ولا يتطلب
قبولا فرنسيا في يعني انطلاقا من ما ذكرت
نحاول ان نناقش خيارات الجانب الفرنسي
وهنا اتوجه للسيد ديفيد اوتو انديلي سيد
ديفيد يعني الدكتور زياد يقول بان فرنسا
لا تستطيع الرد بالمثل اذا اي خيارات يبقى
لفرنسا كيف يمكن ان ترد
فرنسا اعتقد انها مساله
وقت قبل ان يكون على فرنسا ان تستسلم ان
صح القول
ان تقدم ماكرون بتصريح مفاده انه على
اتصال مستمر مع الرئيس منقلب عليه بازوم
يعطي الانطباع لشعب النيجر ان بازوم
لطالما كان دميا بيد فرنسا وهذا طبعا يصعب
موقف فرنسا في النيجر وهذه من سيئات هذه
التصريحات
الفرنسيه المجلس العسكري في نيجر سوف يحرص
على عزل السفير الفرنسي وسوف ينتظر
انتهاء مده تواجد القوات الفرنسيه في
النيجر وهذا قريبا واعتقد ان هذا سيضع
فرنسا في
موقع تنعدم فيه الخيارات قالت فرنسا انها
لا تعترف
بالانقلابيين العسكريين ولكن في نهايه
المطاف هؤلاء العسكريون هم الذين يحظون
على ما يبدو بدعم شعب
نيجر ما يهم من حيث السلطه والسيطره في اي
دوله اذا كانت مستقله هو صوت
الشعب بالتالي انا اعتقد ان فرنسا فقط
تضرب ضربه حظ لا تريد ان تكون في موقف
احراج ولكن في نهايه المطاف سيكون على
فرنسا ان تضعن وان تغادر وهنا سوف يكون
عليها ذلك صعبا لا خيار اخر امام انا لا
ارى ان الاقو سوف تقوم بتدخل عسكري سي
ديد يعني اكثر من نقطه اشرت اليها لابد من
التوقف عندها منها بان التصريحات المتعلقه
بباز وعلاقه بازوم بالسلطات الفرنسيه انما
تظهر هذا الرئيس كما قلت دميا في يد فرنسا
ولكن منطلقات فرنسا مختلفه منطلقات فرنسا
بان مازوم هو رئيس منتخب جرى انتخابه
نتيجه تصويت شعبي وعمليه
ديمقراطيه هذا ليس قرارا تتخذه فرنسا
اطلاقا هذه ازمه داخليه الانقلاب يعتبر
ازمه داخليه ويجب التعامل معه ضمن المنطقه
لا يعود الى فرنسا ان تتخذ موقفا بهذا
الموضوع اذا كانت الحكومه الانتقاليه التي
اسستها القياده الانقلابيه العسكريه قد
اعتبرت ان بازوم لم يعد الرئيس وانه على
فرنسا ان تغادر بقواتها اعتقد ان فرنسا
تحاول تاخير العمليه وتكسب لكي تكسب الوقت
ولكن هذا يزيد الوضع سوءا لان ماكرون صار
اكثر
احراجا هو تحدث عن بازوم واعتقد انه بدا
يرى ان التاثير الفرنسي بدا يضمحل في هذه
المستعمرات
القديمه طيب الدكتور خليل اشار الدكتور
زياد ماجد الى نقطه تتعلق بان ان فرنسا
غير قادره على التدخل الا اذا حصل شيء
للسفير تطور الاحداث هو ما وضع فرنسا في
هذا المازق ام او في هذا الوضع ام هي سع
لحادثه معينه لتبرر اي تدخل في حال قامت
بذلك لا اعتقد ذلك نحن اذاء موقف متطور
لحد بعيد جزء رئيسي من شرعيه الانقلاب في
اليجر يقوم على التخلص من الوجود ما يسمي
الوجود الاستعمار الفرنسي وبالتالي هناك
عنصر مهم جدا متعلق بالدعم الشعبي سواء
كان بشكل حقيقه او بشكل مفتعل ه هؤلاء
الانقلابيون جاؤوا للسلطه على خلفيه
التخلص من وجود استعماري فرنسي في شكله
الجديد سواء من خلال وجود على الارض
بالفعل على الاقل 1500 جندي فرنسي موجودون
هناك منذ سنوات على الاقل منذ عده سنوات
خاصه بعد انقلاب مالي وانتقال جزء مهم من
القوات العسكريه الفرنسيه في مال التي
ذهبت هناك في عمليه بخان قبل حوالي 10 عام
من الان ذهبوا الى الى النيجر ايضا جزء
منه اقتصادي متعلق بالاعتماد الكبير جدا
لفرنسا على موارد الطبيعيه في النيجر خاصه
ما يتعلق باليورانيوم الذي يمثل على الاقل
20% من انتاج الكهرباء في فرنسا وبالتالي
هناك حاجه لذلك خاصه في ظل وجود ازمه
متعلقه باستيراد النفط من روسيا وبالتالي
فرنسا لم تعد ليها ادوات كثيره فيما يتعلق
بالموقف من النيجر جزء رئيس من هذه الازمه
الحاليه عدم قبول فرنسا بالوضع الجديد في
النيجر الخاصه في ظل وجود علاقات ط وقويه
مع الرئيس المقلب علي محمد بزوم الذي سمح
بشكل او اخر بوجود نوع من التعاون العسكري
والاستراتيجي والاقتصادي المهم مع فرنسا
وبالتالي هي تخشى من عدم وجود هذا الدور
بعد ذلك تخشى كما قال الدكتور زياد قبل
قليل من طردها من اخر حبات العنقود اللي
كان موجود في في في الغرب الافريقي خاصه
بالامس بعد او قبل ايام بعد انقلاب
الجابون رغم وجود خلاف كبير بين الحالتين
لكن في شكل واخر هناك لازل حتى هذه اللحظه
على ما يبدو وهم فرنسي بالبقاء في افريقيا
انا اعتقد ان فرنسا لازالت تعيش في مرحله
ما قبل الانقلاب واعتقد ان عليها ان تقبل
هناك وضع جديد رغم سو هذا الوضع ورغم عدم
القبول من الناحيه الشرعيه لانه في
النهايه هذا قد يدر بمصالح فرنسا في
المستقبل وبالتالي انا في رايي شخصي انه
اوراق الضغط الفرنسيه القليله لحد بعيد
خاصه في ظل عدم وجود دعم امريكي تحديدا
لاي تحرك عسكري على الارض سواء من قبل
قوات الاكواس او من قبل حتى فرنسا لو فكرت
في ذلك واعتقد ان هذا الامر قد يكون
مستبعد لحد ب طيب يعني كيف يمكن تفسير عدم
وجود دعم امريكي كيف يمكن تفسير اختلاف
الرؤى حسب ما يبدو بين فرنسا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي ارسلت مبعوثيها
الى المنطقه ويبدو موقفها يعتمد الخيار
الدبلوماسي كحل وحيد يعني بعيد عن اي
خيارات
عسكريه هناك ثلاث محددات رئيسيه للموقف
الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالنيجر المحدد الاول
متعلق بمك فاحه الجماعات المتطرفه هناك
خاصه المحسوبه على تنظيم القاعده والمحسوب
على تنظيم الدوله الاسميه دي تمثل تهديد
كبير جدا للامن الافريقي والامن الالي
بشكل عام النجر تمثل ايضا قاعده عسكريه
مهمه خاصه فيما يتعلق بالطيارات المسيره
الامريكيه فقد تكون اكبر قاعده خارج
امريكا فيما يتعلق باستخدام الطيارات
المسيره فيما يتعلق بتتبع والتخلص
واستهداف الجماعات المطرفه هناك الامر
الثاني متعلق بشكل واضح جدا بمواجهه
النفوذ الروسي هناك خاصه في ظل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا والوجود كثيف جدا
لقوات فاجن الروسيه في هذا الحزام
الافريقي من اول تشاد وغنيا والنيجر ومالي
وبوركينا فاسو وافريقيا الوسطى هناك ما
يشبه امبراطوريه روسيه قامت فاجنر
بتشييدها على مدار اخر عده اعوام واخر
عشره اعوام هذا يمثل ن نفوذ كبير جدا
لروسيا في الصراع مع امريكا الامر الثالث
متعلق بالتواجد الصيني ايضا هناك ونحن
ازاء تنافس الصيني امريكي جيو استراتيجي
واقتصادي وامني واستخباراتي تمثل افريقيا
جزء رئيسي من هذا التنافس وبالتالي تمثل
النيجر يعني دوله مهمه جدا لامريكا ولذلك
راينا ان موقف الامريكا موقف لحد بعيد
يتبع ما اسميه سياسه الباب الموارب او
سياسه الغموض الاستراتيجي بمعنى اخر تؤكد
على دعم الموقف الديمقراطي والذي قد يعني
ضمنا عوده محمد بزوم الى السلطه لكن ايضا
لم تسمي ما حدث في النجر باعتباره انقلاب
هذا يترتب عليه اوضاع قانونيه وسياسيه
تمنع تقديم اي دعم عسكري او دعم اقتصادي
او دعم مالي للحكومات اللي تاتي من خلال
الانقلابات وبت الموقف الامريكي موقف لحد
بعيد تتبع مقاربه حذره تقوم على الحل
الدبلوماسي على الحوار وتستبعد بشكل او
باخر الخيار العسكري وهذا ايضا يعقد المقف
الفرنسي خاصه بظل عدم وجود دعم امريكي لاي
تحرك عسكري على الارض من قبل الاقا طيب
اشرت الى عناصر متعدده اريد ان اعود
للدكتور زياد ماجد دكتور زياد اشار
الدكتور خليل الاني الى وجود قوات فاجنر
اشاره وزير الدفاع الفرنسي بان الجو
المعادي لفرنسا في افريقيا تقف وراءه
الدعايه الروسيه الا يحتم ذلك على فرنسا
تصرفا معينا ذكرت بانها تعلمت دروس
بوركينا فاسو
ومالي لن تعترف بالسلطه الانقلابيه ولكنها
هل ستنسحب هل ستسحب قواتها من
النيجر نعم انا اعتقد ان يعني هناك مشكله
في العلاقه الفرنسيه الافريقيه سابقه على
ولايه ماكرون ولو انه مازال جزءا منها من
ناحيه فرنسا هي دوله استعماريه سابقه من
ناحيه ثانيه هناك في فرنسا ما يس مم
بالفرس افريك او بالارتباط الوثيق بين
رجال اعمال فرنسيين وسياسيين افريقيين وما
يتضمن ذلك من شبكات فساد وزبائن وهناك
البعد الامني الاستراتيجي الان بسبب اوضاع
منطقه الساحل ووجود خلايا لتنظيم القاعده
وللدول الاسلاميه فيها هذه الامور مجتمعه
تعقد الرؤيه الفرنسيه والتخلص الفرنسي من
ارث الماضي من جهه وفي نفس الوقت تجعل
الدعايه الروسيه في افريقيا قابله للتصديق
في اوساط تعادي فرنسا عاطفيا لاسباب
تاريخيه مبرره وايضا لاسباب ترتبط
باستغلال العلاقه مع سياسيين فاسدين وغير
ذلك من امور التحدي على الاداره الفرنسيه
الان هو كيف يمكن ان توفق بين هيبه دوله
مثل فرنسا يفترض ان يكون لموقفها تاثيرات
ميدانيه بما في ذلك فيما يتعلق بوجود قوات
هناك وفي نفس الوقت القبول بان المجتمعات
الافريقيه تتغير وبانه لا يكفي لفهم ما
يجري لوم فاجنر والمرتزقه الروس والدعايه
الروسيه وهي بالمناسبه يعني شكل من اشكال
الامبرياليه الجديده ولو انها ليست غربيه
هناك ضروره للقول بان ما كان يجري في
السابق لم يعد ممكنا في العلاقه الفرنسيه
الافريقيه وفي نفس الوقت لا يمكن نفي ان
موسكو بشكل اساسي وربما بيكين احيانا
تستفيد وتحرض من اجل انهاء الحضور الفرنسي
المباشر لا اعتقد ان سحب القوات الفرنسيه
مطروح فبقاؤها بالنسبه لفرنسا امر
استراتيجي لكن طبعا تعول فرنسا مره اخرى
على الوساطات الافريقيه اكواس و وغيرها
وعلى الموقف الامريكي لايجاد
ربما حل تسويه تحفظ ما وجه فرنسا ولا توفر
غطاء للانقلابيين بل تدفع نحو يعني انتقال
سلطه او نحو اتفاقات جديده بقاء القوات
الفرنسيه حسب ما تقول مستمر وحسب ضيوفي
الثلاث الادوات الفرنسيه ليست بكثيره ولكن
ماذا عن سلطات الانقلاب التي كانت قد
اتهمت فرنسا ايضا باستغلال اكواس لشن حرب
على النيجر وصلت على صعيد اخر تحذيراتها
مما تقول انها تهديدات اكواس بالتدخل الع
عسكري فقد دع رئيس اركان الجيش الذي عينه
قاده الانقلاب موسى سالو بارمو الجيش
للاستعداد لصد اي هجوم محتمل في هذا
الاطار وهنا اعود ل للسيد ديفيد اوتو
اندلي يعني هي رساله لمن سيد ديفيد الحديث
عن استعداد الجيش لصد اي هجوم الذي جاء
على على لسان رئيس
الاركان
الانقلابيون العسكريون في النيجير قد
اوضحوا الموضوع قالوا انهم مستعدون لاي
محاوله تدخل عسكري هذه الرساله موجهه
مباشره الى دول الاعضاء في الايكواس
هذه الدول التي وافقت على تفعيل عمل
الاحتياطي لديها ايضا رساله لفرنسا بان
هؤلاء الانقلابيين لديه
دعم من الشعب في النيجر لقد راينا محاولات
لاستقطاب افراد الشعب الى الجيش ولكن هذه
الرساله ايضا هي موجهه الى الشعب نفسه
داخل النيجر ان هذه لحظه بقاء واستمراريه
وان الانقلابيين العسكريين يقاتلون حربا
ضد القمع والاستعمار الفرنسي الوجود
الفرنسي في البلاد هل يمكن ان تستخدم هنا
سيد ديفيد يعني هل يمكن استخدام الشعب
كورقه للتخلص من الوجود الفرنسي او لطرد
السفير الفرنسي هل هذا الاحتمال وارد في
ظل التصعيد المستمر من قبل السلطات
الانقلابيه ضد فرنسا
ووجودها هذا بالتحديد التكتيك الذي
يستخدمه الانقلابيون العسكريون من خلال
اذا استخدام الشعب الذي يتظاهر امام
السفاره الفرنسيه والقواعد الفرنسيه
العسكريه كذلك يجب الحذر من عدم حصول اي
هجمات ضد هذه المصالح الفرنسيه اذا من جه
لدينا الانقلابيون الذين يدركون ان هذا قد
يكون فخا تستغله فرنسا وقد تتمنى ان يحصل
اعتداءات مباشره على مصالحها وقد تسخر ذلك
كمبرر من اجل
الرد يحرص على مغادره فرنسا لا يمكن
لفرنسا ان تبقى في اي دوله اذا كان الشعب
يطالب برحيلها ولا
يريدها هذا التكتيك استخدم في مالي
وبوركينا فاسو والانقلابيون فهموا ان هذا
قد نجح وسينجح في النيجر وهذه مساله وقت
دكتور خليل عناني التعويل على اكواس
وامكانيه ان ياتي الحل من داخل البيت
الافريقي هل ترى ب جدواه في هذه المرحله
خاصه بان اكواس تبدو وكانها يعني غير
قادره على التحرك بشكل فعال تتحدث عن او
تلوح بالخيار العسكري ولكن يبدو ان هنالك
تعقيدات جم امام امكانيه اجراء او امام
امكانيه الفعل
عسكريا هذا صحيح لحد بعيد انا اعتقد احد
الاخطاء الاستراتيجيه لا كواس انها لوواحد
بالخير العسكري مبكرا جدا عندما لم تقم به
فقط لد بعيد جزء الرئيس من هيبتها ومن
صورتها امام شعوبها حتى قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر انا اعتقد انان اكواس لديها ادوات
محدوده جدا اولا هناك حاله انقسام داخل
اكواس بنتكلم على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه
ثلاث دول خارج مساله دعم من اي تدخل عسكري
بتتكلم على مالي وبرك كنا فاسو طبعا
والنيجر وتشاد تقف على الحياد وبالتالي س
هناك اجماع داخل اكواس حول استخدام الخير
العسكري فيما يتعلق بعدد اعاده الاوضاع
اللي كانت عليه قبل الانقلاب وبالتالي
اعاده محمد زوم السلطه الامر الثاني متعلق
بالقطه العسكريه لاقواس اكواس ليست منظمه
مثلا مثل حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو او حتى
مثل الاتحاد الافريقي او الاتحاد الاوروبي
بنتكلم على منظومه او مجموعه اقتصاديه
سياسيه تنمويه قد تكون امنيه لكنها ليست
عسكريه وبالتالي ليس هناك قدرات عسكريه
كبيره قد تسمح بوجود تدخل عسكري الامر
الثالث متعلق بانه يعني ادوات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه قد تكون اكثر جدوه لماذا هناك
اعتماد كبير جدا لنيجر على على المساعدات
الاقتصاديه الخارجيه بنتكلم على الاقل
اقتصاد يقوم على
40% من من من حجمه عدد الدعم الخارجي
وبالتالي ربما كان استخدام البعد
الاقتصادي قد يكون اكثر اهميه اكثر جدوه
وايضا الحوار ليس ليس من الممكن تخيل وجود
تدخل عسكري في ظل هذه الاوضاع المعقده
خاصه في ظل عدم وجود اولا دعم امريكي صريح
دعم جزائري الجزائري طبعا لاعب مهم جدا في
هذا الاطار ربما بما يكون الامر الان
متعلق باعطاء مساحه اخصار لو سمحت نعم
الخير السياسي والدبلوماسي اكثر منه خير
العسكري نعم وبطبع تشاد ليست ضمن دول
الاكواس والدول الاخرى بكينا فاسو مالي
معلقه العضويه على كل الاحوال الى هنا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج وراء الخبر
ولكن قبل ذلك لابد من شكر ضيوفي الدكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس ومن ابوجا ديفيد اوتو
انديلي مدير مركز جناف للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا ومن لوس انجلس
الدكتور خليل عناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث في المركز
العربي في واشنطن نهايه ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء